[CLICK]
[WHISPERING]
That’s too loud.
You’re going to whisper into your microphone
whatever comes into your mind, you think is going to relax the other person.
[WHISPERING]
Hold my hand.
Is this ASMR?
[LAUGHS]
[WHISPERING]
It’s been a long day at work
and now, you’re home.
[WHISPERING]
… And I’m waiting for you.
Waiting for you at your house.
[WHISPERING]
You’re in the center
of a jelly-filled
[WHISPERING]
doughnut.
Is it bad that I just…
[WHISPERING]
wanted to eat the doughnut?
[LAUGHS]
[WHISPERING]
How was that?
[LAUGHS]
[WHISPERING]
I thought you were gonna say…
[LAUGHS]
[WHISPERING]
you were waiting to kill me!
[LAUGHS]
[WHISPERING]
We’re going to use Zippo lighters to make ASMR sounds.
[CLICKS]
[WHISPERING]
Oh, wow!
[SCRATCHING]
[WHISPERING]
Ohhh.
– Yours was built for rubbing.
– Right?
[CRACKLE]
[WHISPERING]
Ooh, see, that is like being in front of a fire.
And the kids, were never heard from again.
[BLOWING]
[WHISPERING]
All your ASMRs are really creepy.
[LAUGHS]
[CLICK]
[WHISPERING]
Oooohhhhhh!
Now we’re going to try to make ASMR
[WHISPERING]
with scissors and paper.
[SNIP]
[WHISPERING]
It sounds like the wind is really blowing and you’re like–
[RUSTLE]
[WHISPERING]
“The view up here’s really amazing!”
This isn’t giving me tingles, it’s just fun to cut stuff.
[FURIOUS CUTTING]
[WHISPERING]
Robin!
It definitely made me feel very weird
[WHISPERING]
and also, whispering’s not easy. My throat hurts.
It takes you away from, like, all of the daily thoughts that you have.
[WHISPERING]
You can just let yourself rely on your senses, entirely.